♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE GYM IN
NEW JERSEY, LIKE ALL GYMS, IS A
PLACE WHERE ATHLETES GO TO WORK
OUT ON MACHINES, BUT IT’S ALSO A
METAPHOR FOR MAN AGAINST THE
MACHINE.
THE GYM, ONE OF THE FEW
BUSINESSES IN NEW JERSEY TO DEFY
THE STATE’S TRUCK ONLY AND
SHUTDOWN ORDERS ON GYMS AND
FITNESS CENTERS, WE’VE BROUGHT
YOU MANY UPDATES ON THE STORY.
I TALKED TO THE OWNERS AFTER
THEY WERE ARRESTED -- THAT WAS
NOT ENOUGH TO BREAK THE
DETERMINATION.
NOW THEIR BUSINESS LICENSE HAS
BEEN REVOKED IN A POLITICAL VOTE
CALLED FOR BY THE MAYOR.
THEY STARTED LIVING IN THE GYM
AFTER A JUDGE ORDERED THE DOORS
LOCKED AND AS WE PROMISED, WE
WANTED TO BRING YOU AN UPDATE ON
WHERE THEY STAND TONIGHT.
IAN SMITH AND FRANK ARE THE
OWNERS OF THE GYM, COURAGEOUS
MEN BOTH, THEY JOIN US NOW.
GENTLEMEN, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
I WILL JUST THROW THIS TO BOTH
OF YOU.
WHAT IS THE STATUS TONIGHT?
ARE YOU STILL WELCOMING PATRONS
INTO YOUR BUSINESS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAD OUR BUSINESS LICENSE
STRIPPED YESTERDAY.
WE KNEW GOING AND WHAT THE VOTE
WAS GOING TO BE AND IT WAS
EXACTLY WHAT WE WERE TOLD IT WAS
GOING TO BE FROM OUR SOURCES.
WE WERE TOLD IT WAS GOING TO BE
5-1.
I WAS PRESENT AT THE MEETING
WHILE FRANK KIND OF HELD THE
FORT DOWN AND IT WAS VERY CLEAR
AS SOON AS WE WALKED IN THAT
THEY WEREN’T THERE TO ACCOMPLISH
THE MISSION AND THAT MISSION WAS
TO REVOKE OUR BUSINESS LICENSE
AND ENFORCE THE WILL OF
GOVERNOR MURPHY AND ONCE THEY
DID, WE JUST GOT BACK TO
BUSINESS AS USUAL.
>> Tucker: AS YOU’VE NOTED
MANY TIMES IN THE SHOW.
NOT A SINGLE TRANSMISSION OF THE
CORONAVIRUS HAS OCCURRED IN YOUR
ESTABLISHMENT.
THERE’S NO MEDICAL REASON TO DO
THIS, BUT YOU DEFIED THE WILL OF
AN AUTHORITARIAN GOVERNOR AND
HE’S DETERMINED TO CRUSH YOU.
SO HOW DO YOU THINK THIS WILL
END?
>> WE BELIEVE IT’S GOT TO END --
WE HAVE [INDISCERNIBLE] ON OUR
SIDE AND WE ARE MANDATING THAT
HE ACTUALLY PROVED TO US -- I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIS SIDE TO
THAT.
SHOW THAT OUR JIM IN MOVIE
THEATERS AND INDOOR DINING ARE
DANGEROUS AND ON TOP OF THAT I
WANT TO SEE THE SCIENCE THAT
SHOWS THAT A NEW JERSEY TRANSIT
BUS CAN HAVE 60 PEOPLE IN 340
SQUARE FEET AND THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE FULL CONTACT
SPORTS OUTSIDE AND EVERYBODY EVE
ELSE, SHOW ME THE SCIENCE AND I
WILL CLOSE MY DOORS.
IF NOT, I’M HERE TO FIGHT UNTIL
THE END.
>> Tucker: SO I MEAN, YOU GUYS
STARTED THIS AS A GYM, AS A
BUSINESS AND NOW YOU’RE
EMBROILED IN THIS NATIONWIDE
CONTROVERSY.
WHAT A JUST BE EASIER TO MOVE TO
FLORIDA AND BY A FRANCHISE AND
FORGET ALL THIS?
WHY ARE YOU CONTINUING?
>> YOU KNOW, IT WOULD CERTAINLY
BE EASIER.
BUT FROM THE ONSET, THIS WAS
ABOUT MUCH MORE THAN JUST
KEEPING OUR BUSINESS OPEN.
WE SMELLED THAT THIS WAS
POLITICAL VERY EARLY ON AND OUR
HUNCH WAS RIGHT.
AND WE DON’T WANT TO SEE THE
COUNTRY THAT WE LOVE AND THE WAY
OF LIFE THAT WE LOVE BE RUINED
WITH A POLITICAL AGENDA.
SO WE KNEW WHAT WE WERE STEPPING
UP TO.
I DON’T THINK THAT WE THOUGHT IT
WAS GOING TO GET THIS FAR, BUT
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TALK OUR
TAIL AND RUN ON THIS ONE.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE THIS ALL THE
WAY THROUGH BECAUSE IT IS THAT
IMPORTANT.
>> IT’S ABOUT OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS, IN A MATTER WHAT AND
EVERYBODY’S CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS.
>> Tucker: THAT’S RIGHT.
YOU SMELLED THAT IT WAS
POLITICAL EARLY ON, I THINK
THAT’S THE KEY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, INCLUDING EVEN
THE SHOW KIND OF MOVED FORWARD
WITH TOTAL CREDULITY THAT PEOPLE
WOULD TRY TO DO THE RIGHT THING
FOR THE COUNTRY.
YOU WERE SMART TO KNOW THAT THEY
ARE NOT.